five people have been killed when an suv
drove into a christmas parade in the
state of wisconsin another 40 people
were injured including several children
as a word of warning there is disturbing
video coming up right now
videos posted on social networks show
the moment the vehicle rammed into the
crowd the police chief of the city where
the incident happened said a person of
interest is now in custody local media
quote law enforcement sources stating
that the suspect's been identified as a
39 year old man with a criminal record
and that they're ruling out a terror
link for now police are also
investigating whether he was fleeing a
crime at the time
kevin owens spoke to a witness at the
parade
it's a big popular annual thing and uh
people come from um different towns and
stuff to do it so it's kind of like to
kick off the holiday season they were
probably
i don't know 40 000 people there you
were filming it you kind of saw it all
firsthand um before we have a talk about
it let's just show our viewers just a
little clip from some of what you filmed
[Music]
oh my gosh it was crazy we were the
first
point where he entered the parade at so
we were right around the corner so
when you see that he swerved around the
truck there was a road and then that's
where he entered at so we were the first
people that he made contact with yeah
and he was doing at least 35 or 40 miles
an hour down the crowded street
it was just
absolute instant chaos he managed to go
almost the entire
uh
length of the parade when he went
through our band he struck
eight kids were down and the the kid
that i was administering first aid to
both of his feet were like ran over and
his legs were broken your daughter's
band was performing that parade i guess
that's why you were filming there what
went through your head absolutely this
must all be so unexpected and it takes
you just a moment to work out what's
happening around you first thing that
went through my head after i realized i
couldn't stop the guy was
get the kids off the street into safety
there's a lot of people
who who've never seen that i mean
unfortunately i've seen
trauma before um
so i just started getting people in
groups connecting them with each other
getting them to safety i'm trained in
combat first aid so i started you know
checking the pulses making sure the kids
are breathing
you know not moving
telling people to get some blankets out
here my family and kids are still
traumatized we were talking with the
police officers until about one o'clock
because
we actually saw the driver's face and
we're giving descriptions most of my
kids are still sleeping now i i really
couldn't sleep so
you